These people are eating
thousands of calories of McDonald's
in a single sitting.
That's a pretty awful idea.
But do you know what
might be worse?
Eating McDonald's food
for an entire year.
Well, on today's episode
we're going to show you.
What's your favorite meal
at McDonald's?
Let's say you get a Big Mac,
a medium fries, and don't forget about
that Coca-Cola.
This is a pretty average meal
at McDonald's, and it's over
Which is nearly half of a person's
daily calorie intake.
And this is just one of your meals.
For this challenge,
we're going to have you eat breakfast,
lunch, dinner, and you can't forget
about snacking.
Would your body be able to handle
this for an entire year?
We've all had weeks where
we've eaten nothing but fast food,
so your first week of eating
McDonald's shouldn't be too bad.
You might feel a bit
constipated and gassy.
Since you're not getting enough
fiber in your digestive system.
And you'll start feeling more
sluggish and tired.
You can try the grilled chicken
and salads,
but you'll quickly realize
they're not filling enough.
And all those greasy fries
and burgers are giving you
some slight heartburn.
But it isn't so bad that
you need to see a doctor.
You've been eating McDonald's
for a couple of weeks now,
and you're starting to get a bit
bored with your go-to items.
So you start eating your way
through the menu.
Chicken, wraps,
breakfast sandwiches,
maybe even a salad or two.
But every time you choose a
burger over a salad,
here's what happens inside your body.
Your pancreas will get an alert
that there are high fat and high carb
meals on the way,
and release insulin.
The more frequently you eat this stuff,
the more your insulin levels will spike.
Going up and down,
which could lead to diabetes.
But that's in the future.
Right now, you'll be dealing with
more acne than normal.
This is due to the high amount of
carbs, and higher blood sugar levels
from eating all this food.
So you've been eating burgers,
fries, chicken nuggets,
and whatever else is on the menu
at McDonald’s for half a year.
This means you've been eating well
above the recommended number
of daily calories.
So it's no surprise that you've put on
some pounds around your waist.
This extra weight will put pressure
on your lungs and heart.
Even climbing upstairs could
make you out of breath.
Your cholesterol levels are
incredibly high,
and your arteries are at risk
of getting blocked.
Now your year-long experiment
is coming to an end.
Let's take a look at what you've done.
You’ve spent about
on fast food.
And consumed well over
And, oh man,
I don't even want to think about
how much weight you've gained.
After all that,
you're probably pre-diabetic
due to all the sugar you've consumed,
not to mention the sodium.
After your second meal of the day,
you would have exceeded your
recommended maximum daily value of
So, you've lost a lot of money,
gained a bunch of weight,
and have a long list of health problems.
This diet was a terrible idea.
But luckily,
if you accept a challenge to do this,
McDonald's does have some
healthier options for you.
You can always track the calories
on the menu to help you make
better decisions.
So, if you decide to do this,
which we don't recommend,
you can spend your year eating
grilled chicken,
salads, and apple slices.
It would be hard
to resist those burgers,
but it can be done.
So you just barely survived
this challenge.
What about another one
that's less lethal?
Like going vegan, maybe?
We'll see what that challenge brings
on another episode of